on to uvalde texas where parents are
making fresh demands for accountability
from law enforcement after the austin
american statesman published this photo
you can see armed police officers in a
hallway outside the classroom where 19
children and two teachers were killed
now the time stamp and this is hard
shows it's taken nearly one hour before
the gunman was stopped omar villafranca
is in uvalde omar you were at that
school board meeting attended by the
victims families listen it is hard to
hear that latest detail it makes me
think more anger or outrage and
heartbreak for these families take us
inside the room what was it like
we were filled
by peter arredondo he felt our kids
teachers parents and city and by keeping
him on your staff y'all are continuing
to fellas brett cross's nephew
ten-year-old yuzaya garcia was one of
the 19 school children shot and killed
on may 24th cross joined other families
to demand answers monday night my mom
died protecting her students
but who was protecting my mom
liliana garcia's mother irma was a
teacher who died in the shooting her
father joe died just two days later the
family says of a broken heart at the age
of 16 and age when a girl needs her
parents the most i'm trying to fill the
shoes of both my beloved mother and
father the best i can
the meeting came after the austin
american statesman obtained this
surveillance photo showing officers
outside the classroom where the gunman
opened fire
the photo is time stamped 11 52 a.m 29
minutes before the gunman fired another
round of shots and nearly an hour before
law enforcement killed him it's more
evidence that indicates police waited
before stopping the gunman despite
having rifles and at least one ballistic
shield earlier this month uvalde cisd
police chief pete arredondo insisted
quote not a single responding officer
ever hesitated even for a moment to put
themselves at risk to save the children
many believe aerodondo should be fired
including angel garza who lost his
ten-year-old step-daughter a marie i had
an officer from every department
look me in the eye
and ask me to trust them
how are we supposed to continue our
lives here
knowing that those people that are
supposed to protect us
let down our family
a state house committee is investigating
the police response in uvalde but they
have not talked to arredondo just yet
meanwhile negotiations for national gun
reform legislation are continuing in
washington d.c but they're coming up on
a deadline because lawmakers are about
to go on a two-week recess for the
fourth of july
nate
our hearts are still with the people of
vivaldi omar thank you